Today's October 7th,
and although I wasn't planning on making any videos today
because we just have a lot going on,
um, I wanted to Mark this day
because it's been a year since Hamas attacked Israel,
took hostages, and Israel has retaliated with a mass casualty
bombing and displacement of the people in Gaza.
I never thought in a million years hostages would be taken for a year.
I never thought that a year later,
the violence would still be continuing.
And through this year,
I've Learned that it is so hard to teach our kids
that peace on earth is a feasible goal
when you see people hate with such vigor.
And over this year,
I've Learned something about myself and about other people,
and that is that most hate
comes from the fear and the misunderstanding
of people who are not like you.
The belief that certain people are inherently bad
and certain people are inherently good or just or moral.
I have seen people dehumanize an entire nation of people.
And you can assume, with whatever belief systems you have,
which group of people I'm talking about,
but it's true for both.
And I've Learned that the best thing that I can do
to actually impact change,
to try and create a peaceful world for my children,
for myself, for our future as humans on this planet,
is to not give in to the other ring of others,
to not believe that groups of people are inherently Evil
or have nefarious purposes.
To try to learn instead of be afraid.
To keep my heart open and not harden it.
To not run into the open arms of what's familiar and easy,
and to sit in the truth that certain things are unjustifiable
for the Jewish people. This is the week between Rosh Hashanah,
our New Year, and Yom Kippur,
which is where we make repentance.
I hope we can all reflect on what we can do individually
to bring about a more peaceful world,
and how we can help get the hostages home and the people of Gaza safer.